so we've seen two of the waiters now
ready for the main course so are you
ready for the main ones I won't at the
same time no I mean I ready to order
than we've ordered all right are you
ready yeah yeah we're good
sometimes we get overwhelmed and we just
like we'll help each other yeah that's
of course obviously here lack of
communication
yeah but it's not a rush that gets set
across the board to everybody doesn't it
in terms of Pat's dear yeah I don't
think it looks wildly appetizer looks a
little bit dry the wood pigeon has been
minced to such a degree you can't
distinguish it from any other meal in my
opinion I think mincing up the word
pigeon ISM is an hour
they didn't they didn't mince out that
little piece of work pigeon shouldn't
leave bones in it
you know I for so bloody dangerous bone
yeah that's fine things were clumsy yeah
but it took me to be honest review just
happen ever so often he's just yeah care
and attention could I have a little side
order tabbouleh yeah just a little a
little bit of tabbouleh it was almost as
if he was too busy to deal with us oh
I've got some of that I wanted a little
bowl of tabbouleh I will double it but
it is a bit perplexing you've had two
occasions now where they've been a
mistake because they're not
communicating with each other
excuse me I always seem to Bulli I
wanted to it was time to be up to be
honest with you I'm now confused about
what I've told which waiter as mutter
buoy thank you so the Tiberias arrived
but it was a good 10 minutes now to ask
two different waiters and it got
delivered by a third fragmented such as
opposed to two waiters looking after
they've been interrupted for five times
with five different waiters it's a busy
restaurant and you know you get to not
be still control it's no excuse I
haven't filled our water up since we
arrived
I'm just going to leave that there it's
in a very prominent position we'll just
see if they fit it up so I have a little
more water
it's over two hours in certainly water
and now I've asked for some but it still
hasn't come
excuse me types of water are the water
I'm just cuz it's a Moroccan restaurant
doesn't mean we have the water retention
ability of a camel exactly
oh we've been waiting hour or whatever
they should be waiting that long for
water if it knows when for me to wash
toilets oh yeah yeah it's separating
he's made so many waiters and none of
them noticed that doing the water
basically what can see but you are
somewhat over staff with bodies there
when you've had the egg the knife the
tenth waiter hit the table you feel a
bit sort of Jesus we are just yeah I
want to conveyor belt him to be passed
along to the next person there's a
restaurant dishing transport you to
another place you can eat good food
actually good
because not fun here and if going out
and eating our own restaurant is about
having fun and excitement and sharing
that with your friends then this takes a
lot of mobsters food's good
bloody good a few areas of tightening up
service needs to come together glamorous
great attentive individuals but they
need to play as a team and then when the
teams all singing off that hem sheet
you've got one amazing ration
yes but get constructive criticism you
go back can we sort it out that's what
we get therefore sometimes I used to
hurt the mouse but you get back up again
is a much stronger